un gouvernement incompétent qui détruit
l'industrie des fruits de mer
voilà le slogan que l'on pouvait lire
lundi dans les rues de londres où des
centaines de pêcheurs britanniques
s'étaient réunis pour montrer leur
mécontentement avec la sortie de l'union
européenne et du marché unique
les droits de douane ont été rétablis
tout comme la paperasse pour exporter
coquillages et crustacés avec pour
conséquence des retards d'expédition
potentiellement désastreux pour la
conservation de ces produits frais en
gros nous sommes ici pour voir si nous
pouvons obtenir quelques changements
pour notre industrie les crustacés après
le break cite personne ne pensait que
tout cela allait arriver
mais ce qu'il nous demande de faire
chaque semaine est tout simplement pas
possible avec des fruits de mer vivant
nous n'allons pas nous en sortir avec
toute la paperasse mais il faut
rationaliser notre activité c'est juste
que les coquillages vivants ne
fonctionne pas comme nous le demande
lors du référendum de 2016 les pêcheurs
du royaume uni avait pourtant
majoritairement voté en faveur du bric
site espérant reprendre le contrôle des
eaux britanniques le premier ministre
boris johnson a depuis évoqué des
retards de démarrage et a promis une
aide pour ces professionnels en
difficulté est bien dans la mesure où
lits actuellement des problèmes de mise
en route avec des gens qui ne
remplissent pas les bons formulaire ou
des malentendus et que ce n'est pas la
faute des gens nous allons bien sûr les
aider et des fonds ont été mis en place
pour cela c'est pourquoi nous avons créé
un fonds de 100 millions de livres
sterling pour aider les gens avec leurs
bateaux pour aider l'industrie de la
transformation du poisson et rajeunir
une industrie historique au royaume uni
le gouvernement le soutiendra nous
pensons que l'opportunité est énorme
en décembre dernier londres et bruxelles
avaient trouvé un accord in extremis sur
la question de la pêche un sujet devenu
source de crispation majeure entre les
deux parties et qui semble appelé à le
rester